[Music]
sean watson
is so freaking awesome it's good to have
you man our homie our homie patrick
mahomey
i don't sing that song for my own
personal uh just fun
all right that's twice today i hope
we're not gonna have that 38 more times
over the next four weeks here's hoping
to talk to
all right but uh that's our little intro
for the chris sims top 40 quarterback
rankings we talked earlier about guys
who didn't make it sorry blake bortles
sorry teddy bridgewater at number 40 was
tyrod or terrad taylor the backup now of
the la chargers so we have reached the
moment in the show where it is time to
unveil
number
39 on the chris sims list of top 40 nfl
quarterbacks yeah number 39 will be colt
mccoy yes hook'em horns texas colt mccoy
uh
very close between him and ty rod taylor
in fact i kind of made this list too a
little bit before i knew that colt mccoy
was still going to be dealing with this
leg injury going into the off season to
where
i could have maybe i know if people are
going to probably get mad at me and go
oh tyrod taylor should be 39 colt mccoy
should be 40. whatever i get it it's
very close here i went with colt mccoy
originally cole mccoy is a talented
football player i mean hey the redskins
were thinking about going into this
season as him as the starting
quarterback when all said and done you
know really when he came in last year
for alex smith i thought they had a
chance to be every bit as good on
offense uh with colt mccoy as alex smith
he's a good athlete mike he's accurate
uh he really has no glaring weakness to
his football game he doesn't have a big
time arm he doesn't have big time speed
but there's nothing i can look at and go
oh he does this you know poorly no he's
got good timing good anticipation knows
where to throw the football can get out
of the pocket and extend plays you know
it's played in some
big moments for the washington redskins
and of course through his college career
so yeah i look at cole mccoy as being
one of the better backups in in all of
football uh it really the big thing for
him is going to be the status of this
leg and what happens to him through
training camp here because he could end
up ultimately being trade bait here at
some point this soft season as well
yeah or possibly being cut i mean it's a
crowded house on that depth chart in
washington with dwayne haskins case
keenum alex smith who isn't on the
roster but you know he'll be on injured
reserve he'll he'll be around and
there's a lot of money invested in him
and see that's the thing how much value
does colt mccoy have as a mentor to a
dwayne haskins as a facilitator to a guy
like case keenum who is new to the
system is alex smith
enough of a guy to do it or you know
mccoy is the only one that's got more
than one year experience with jay gruden
the other guys are all either one year
in like alex smith or brand new like
keenum and haskins yeah no i would i
would believe that colt mccoy can give
dwayne haskins you know
more tutelage as far as what to expect
from jay gruden and the washington
redskins and the little intricacies of
the offense more than anybody there in
the building yeah i mean you're right i
mean alex smith of course has a lot to
offer but he still is not going to know
the offense uh to the extent colt mccoy
is in the years he's been there you know
in that same system so uh yeah i i would
think colt mccoy or dwayne haskins is
probably leaning on a colt mccoy a lot
at this point especially since he's kind
of competing with case keenum colt mccoy
is not out there practicing full speed
can't do anything yet because of issues
with the the surgery and everything like
that in his leg to where uh i would
imagine dwayne haskins is asking colt
mccoy a lot of questions and colt's
probably given him a lot of answers too
because he probably wants to keep that
quarterback competition tight between
dwayne haskins and case keenum so he can
jump in there and get involved and
doesn't want one guy to run away with it
he had a year with the 49ers before
joining washington his first three
seasons though with the browns easy to
forget that he was one of the many names
on the back of that jersey that just has
one quarterback last name after another
started 21 games and had his chance in
2011 13 game starter not a great year he
had 11 interceptions and 11 fumbles now
they recovered nine of the eleven but
still that's way too many times for a
quarterback to put the ball on the
ground and he just didn't do enough to
stave off the the the brandon whedon
experiment that began the next year and
a lot of impatience for uh the
quarterback position in cleveland but
you know when he's had chances
he's he
he hasn't been horrible no problem last
year when his chance finally came after
the alex smith injury he suffered the
broken leg yeah that's been an issue
with him at two separate times of his
career really is you know he's kind of
gets going he's gonna assert himself as
you know something one of those guys
that maybe has a potential starter
slash you know really high-end quality
backup but yeah injuries have been the
issue and yeah he was just kind of
getting it going last year on what was
that monday night in philadelphia when
he broke his leg makes a big run down
the right sidelines you know when you
feel like he's finally getting
comfortable that happens so yeah it's
going to be an interesting offseason
with colt mccoy the redskins you're
right he could end up getting cut at
some point during training camp um he
could end up looking good maybe in the
first few preseason games and a team
that might go oh we need a backup or we
need somebody that's you know got a
little experience you know he could be a
guy that the the the league calls
washington for and acts as for you know
a trade and does something like that as
well
and chris even though kirk cousins later
established himself as the guy in
washington
in 2014 when when rg3 got injured and
cousins came in cousins got benched for
mccoy at one point during that season
now cousins came back but cousins did
get benched and they went with mccoy so
they've seen something there with mccoy
for a while yes they have uh he he grew
as a player once he got out of cleveland
the san francisco washington years he
really started to improve and has had
moments of impressing me
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports